see if you just do it really light it
just picks up the color and then it
doesn't get like
does she
I thought maybe she might think this is
a little tacky you know people have a
love-hate relationship either like wow
that's really cool or how could you soil
the garden like that the soil part well
well I'd say most years these are ready
to do like just before the fourth of
July yeah I always thought yeah it's
kind of like a fourth of July surprise
the first year I saw them do it
it was just on a few over here they had
some of the real big ones I forgotten
the species on that and they were just
blue and it seems like maybe the last
two year or two they've done these well
ephemeral you leave them up for a week
and then you come back in you did heven
well I don't know you guys you guys are
the ones who
oh that's true painting some roses but
though at least I got to paint them red
like a red
you're out of white penis getting more
don't worry
copper is what yeah I told my stepmother
to use copper she has a whole bunch of
her
over the white
but it's still
right
there are a bunch over there
guys
howdy we need the blue
not only we're gonna I think we're just
gonna check it out she likes it don't
want to break it she's writing things
down and I was like laughs and I it's
very difficult for me to do that and her
friend is with her and she's like oh and
I just burst into hysterics it she's
like I was going back to California